And we are back with our 2024 le
just six weeks until Republican
caucus in Iowa.
Candidates are courting one of t
most influential groups.
Evangelical Christians,
specifically white evangelical C
Ron DeSantis recently was endors
prominent evangelical Bob Vander
And he just wrapped up a 99 coun
swing in the Hawkeye State.
But he remains nearly 30 percent
behind Trump in the latest poll
from the Des Moines Register.
Joining us now is Tim Alberta.
He's a staff writer for The Atla
and he has a new book titled The
The Power and the Glory American
Evangelicals in an Age of Extrem
The book comes out tomorrow.
Congratulations, Tim.
So exciting. Thanks, Jay Vander
Pretty certain
that America will not elect Trum
Do other evangelical leaders in
and throughout the country,
do they share that concern and c
Well,
I don't think they share the cer
In fact, when you sort of survey
the rank and file evangelical pa
around the country, as I've done
the last couple of years,
I think there's almost a resigna
to the idea
that, you know, Trump for this s
probably the intermediate term
at least, has a pretty good
hold on a lot of their congregan
And that they're not
going to deviate from him anytim
But Bob Vander Plaats has had so
of a long running feud with Trum
In fact, some of the reporting
that's come out of my book aroun
using disparaging, vulgar langua
to refer to certain Iowa evangel
that was aimed towards
Bob Vander Plotz himself, among
So it's no surprise that he woul
Ron DeSantis.
I don't think that there's any q
that Trump retains
an overwhelming lead among white
evangelicals in Iowa and elsewhe
I think the question really,
at least in a political frame,
Jake, is not whether Trump is wi
big majorities of these voters,
both in the primary and in the g
But how many of these voters sho
next November?
Is there any sort of a falloff
because of the Trump exhaustion?
We see with some of these evange
Ted Cruz his campaign mocked Tru
when Trump
infamously cited two Corinthians
You write, quote, when Cruz's al
using the two Corinthians line
to attack him in the final days
before the Iowa caucuses, Trump
Iowa Republican official,
You know, these so-called
Christians hanging around with T
or some real pieces of shit, unq
I only curse on air when, genera
speaking, when I'm quoting someo
How do Trump
supporting evangelicals square t
The fact that he was ignorant
about Scripture, not to mention
all the other ways in which Dona
is not exactly square with the g
Do they just ignore it,
or are they just happy with the
that he was very responsible
for the overturning of Roe v Wad
How do they justify it to themse
Well, Jake, it's
a great question, obviously.
And there's sort of a fascinatin
psychological arc here to unders
Whereas at this point, eight yea
a lot of these white evangelical
were very uneasy with Trump,
and they viewed his lack of fami
with scripture
and his behavior and his rhetori
They viewed those things as weak
and they sort of entered into th
very uneasy transactional relati
with him where they said, look,
you know, he's the nominee now a
he's going to give us
some of these policy victories
we really want in exchange for o
That transactional relationship
morphed into something else enti
which is to say specifically
that to the point about the
91 indictments and his rhetoric
not letting non-Christians
into the country and you know, T
being a decidedly more antagonis
militant candidate
this time around, especially wit
with his bearing towards
the non-evangelicals in this cou
talking about how he will be the
retribution and how he will esse
wield Christianity as a weapon.
They are all for that, in part
because they have come to view T
as almost a righteous protector,
as someone who
because he is not a Christian hi
he's not bound by biblical virtu
He's not
he doesn't have to play by their
And that's almost his superpower
It gives him an ability to do th
to protect this Christian coalit
if you will, that no other candi
would be willing to do.
In your book, you write about yo
upbringing in the church and eva
such as your dad, who was a past
believed and preached that integ
Integrity was a prerequisite
for political leadership.
But but that seems to have chang
Yeah.
And the simplest explanation for
as to why it's changed is what
you'll hear from a lot of evange
Christians around the country,
which is that they are under sie
which is that Christianity is un
in this country, in the culture
from the secular godless left.
And just look at COVID 19.
They shut down our churches, tra
ism on the march, all of these t
And they will point to that and
you know, desperate times
call for desperate measures.
Donald Trump, this this
you know, if you feel as though
are at the gates, then you might
just be willing to turn to a bar
to do your fighting for you.
Our mutual friend and my boss, J
Goldberg, said this to me the ot
He said, You're almost describin
like a mercenary relationship.
And I said,
that's kind of exactly what it i
for people who feel
that they are threatened in this
They're willing to turn to a man
who shares none of their values.
And in fact, perhaps
that is their greatest attractio
That's fascinating.
There are clear parallels
between the growing divide
in the Republican Party
and in the evangelical community
What do you make of Speaker
Mike Johnson's rapid rise to pow
given his strong religious ident
Yeah, well, you know,
when Mike Johnson says essential
that the Bible is his governing
Jake, you know, that's
that's not a fringe position.
We shouldn't necessarily treat i
something that is far out
of the evangelical mainstream.
I think what's important to reco
and a lot of us are uncomfortabl
even saying this out loud,
but there is very much
an ascendant movement
on the right in this country
that would seek to abolish any s
of firewall between church and s
There will be people working in
Trump term,
and I report on this a bit in th
who are very much invested in th
Of merging the power of the chur
at some official level,
whether it's through a declarati
or some executive order.
But again, we heard Trump,
even in his rhetoric on the camp
a couple of weeks ago, saying fl
this idea that nobody would be a
to come to this country
as a migrant moving forward
unless they are a Christian.
So effectively a religious litmu
So you have real strands
of Christian nationalism
now that are infecting the highe
echelons of the Republican Party
And that's something
the country is going to have to
sooner rather than later.
Tim, Alberta, thank you so much.
And congratulations on the new b
The Kingdom, the Power and the G
American Evangelicals
in an Age of Extremism comes out
Everything Tim writes is fascina
well-written and worth a read.
Congratulations again,
my friend. Thanks, Jack. Appreci